the city of las vegas tweeted over the
weekend that another
mountain lion was spotted just this year
it seems we've had
more than one mountain lion making
appearance in neighborhoods eight news
now reporter sally jaramillo spoke to
the
nevada department of wildlife and a
homeowner who noticed the feline in the
northwest valley she joins us now live
with that story
sally denise many are calling this
a valley trend as now many ring cameras
are all capturing all of the activity
this is one such home
on saturday a mountain lion was
tranquilized right here
animal control then returned it back to
its habitat
gary gibson has lived in the valley
since 2005.
he tells me he has never seen a mountain
lion in his neighborhood gibson became
aware of the activity due to police cars
and animal control vehicles near his
street gibson says police asked everyone
to stay inside while they capture the
animal
behind me is the bureau of land
management
and around here is floyd land park and
they're not building anything there
this is their area out there that's
where they live
doug nielsen with the department of
wildlife says mountain lions in several
parts of the valley
is nothing new and they have no way of
knowing how many different mountain
lions there are
the only way to know if it's the same
one spotted is if it's given an
identifier or a dna sample is compared
to the previous mountain lion
that was captured reporting live in the
northwest part of the valley sally
jaramillo 8 news now
okay well that was a pretty big cat i
mean you see that you see that on your
porch
it's a little unnerving well after those
mountain lion sightings so we asked on
twitter if you our viewers are worried
about
mountain lions maybe coming into your
neighborhood hey look at this the
majority said nah
83 are pretty comfortable with but 17 of
you
live in those neighborhoods makes you a
little nervous brian